anti-semitic incidents are up really
across the country and here in Nevada
it's not much better Ryan Matthey shows
us the numbers and what the Jewish
Community is doing to protect itself
it's a give and take 86 year old Ray
fiol was born in France when World War
II broke out I was three years old her
Jewish Family sent to a labor camp her
father arranged for her to sneak out
unknown to me my parents had already
been taken to Auschwitz and murdered at
the beginning of 1944 and when she got
to the states discrimination continued
what uh hurts now is to see it all come
back in full bloom she's not the only
one in January Boulder City residents
found anti-semitic Flyers posted on
their doors the local rise inspired a
billboard campaign across the valley we
still had over 30 incidents of
anti-isemitism on the ground and yet the
Anti-Defamation League which records
these incidents are finding more
nationally they report a 36 percent rise
in 2022 the highest since 1979. in
Nevada the non-profit jubel long
reported a 64 percent increase from the
year prior Regional ADL director Jolie
bristlin we've seen incidents in the
schools where students are being walking
down the hall saying to Vernon hell go
back to the oven violent attacks verbal
threats and property damage I thought we
were past this that temples like
congregation nurtamed are forced to
respond to we've added more security
guards our services are constantly being
patrolled and and people are being
looked after because you just never know
Anders students they feel free to be
Jewish here but they don't outwardly
show that in the society that they're
assimilated to but despite the hate they
hold on to hope of a more unified future
you have to hope all the time with that
hope I wouldn't be here
now the ADL data shows nationally 10
anti-semitic incidents occur every day
so they urge people who witness or are
the victim of these incidents to report
them because without it programming
cannot be created to fight hate they say